- Nutritionists measured the sugar content
in grams for 32 drinks at Starbucks.
A cumulative relative
frequency graph, let me
underline that, a cumulative
relative frequency graph
for the data is shown below.
So, they have different
on the horizontal axis,
different amounts of
sugar in grams and then,
we have the cumulative
relative frequencies.
Let's just make sure we
understand how to read this.
This is saying that zero or
zero percent of the drinks
have a sugar content,
have no sugar content.
This right over here, this data point,
this looks like it's at the .5 grams
and then this looks like it's at 0.1.
This says that 0.1, or
I guess we could say
10 percent of the drinks that Starbucks
offers has five grams of sugar or less.
This data point tells us that a hundred
percent of drinks at
Starbucks has 50 grams
of sugar or less.
The cumulative relative
frequency, that's why
at each of these points we
say this is the frequency
that has that much sugar or less.
And, that's why it just
keeps on increasing
and increasing as we add more sugar
we're going to see a larger portion
or a larger relative frequency has that
much sugar or less.
So, let's read the first question.
An iced coffee has 15 grams of sugar.
Estimate the percentile of this drink
to the nearest whole percent.
So, iced coffee has 15 grams of sugar
which would be right over here.
And so, let's estimate the percentile.
So, we can see they actually have
a data point right over here and
we can see that 20 percent or 0.2,
20 percent of the drinks that Starbucks
offers has 15 grams of sugar or less.
So, the percentile of this drink,
if I were to estimate it, looks like
it's the relative frequency 0.2 has
that much sugar or less so this percentile
would be 20 percent.
Once again, another way to think about it,
to read this you could
convert these to percentages.
You could say that 20 percent
has this much sugar or less.
15 grams of sugar or
less, so an iced coffee
is in the 20th percentile.
Let's do another question.
So here, we are asked
to estimate the median
of the distribution of drinks.
Hint to think about the 50th percentile.
So, the median, if you were to line up all
of the drinks, you would
take the middle drink.
And so, you could view that as well, what
drink is exactly at the 50th percentile?
So, now let's look at the 50th percentile
would be a cumulative
relative frequency of 0.5,
which would be right over
here on our vertical axis.
Another way to think about
it is 0.5, or 50 percent
of the drinks are going,
if we go to this point
right over here, what
has a cumulative relative
frequency of 0.5.
We see that we are right at
looks like this is 25 grams.
So, one way to interpret
this is 50 percent
of the drinks have less than or have 25
grams of sugar or less.
So, this looks like a pretty good estimate
for the median, for the middle data point.
So, the median is approximately 25 grams
that half of the drinks have
25 grams or less of sugar.
Let's do one more based
on the same data set.
So, here we're asked,
what is the best estimate
for the interquartile range
of the distribution of drinks?
So, the interquartile
range, we wanna figure out
well, what's sitting
at the 25th percentile?
And we wanna think about what's
at the 75th percentile, and then we
want to take the difference.
That's what the interquartile range is.
So, let's do that.
So, first the 25th
percentile, we wanna look
at the cumulative relative
frequency, so 25th
this would be 30th, so
the 25th would be right
around here and so, it looks like the 25th
percentile is that looks
like about, I don't know,
and we're estimating here,
so that looks like it's
about this would be 15, I
would say maybe 18 grams.
So, approximately 18 grams.
Once again, one way to think about it is,
25 percent of the drinks have
18 grams of sugar or less.
Now, let's look at the 75th percentile.
So it's the 70th, 75th
would be right over there.
Actually, I can draw a
straighter line than that.
I have a line tool here.
75th percentile would
put me right over there.
I don't know, that
looks like, I'll go with
39 grams, roughly 39 grams.
And so, what's the
difference between these two?
Well, the difference
between these two, it looks
like it's about 21 grams.
So, our interquartile range, our estimate
of our interquartile
range, looking at this
cumulative relative
frequency distribution,
'cause we're sayin',
hey look, it looks like
the 25th percentile, looks like 25 percent
of the drinks have 18 grams or less.
75 percent of the drinks
have 39 grams or less.
If we take the difference
between these two
quartiles, this is the first quartile,
this is our third quartile.
We're gonna get 21 grams.
Now, if we look at this
choice, the choices
right over here, 20 grams definitely
seems like the best estimate,
closest to what we were able to estimate
based on looking at this cumulative
relative frequency graph.